joining us now is dr tom frieden he's
former director of the cdc he's
currently president and ceo of resolve
to save lives whose mission is to save
100 million lives by preventing heart
disease and epidemics dr freedom we're
really glad you're here at the table
listen we are all covet exhausted we're
over it but covet is not over us does it
make sense to you this ruling and should
we leave it up to people to make their
own decisions to mask or not mask well
i'm a doctor not a lawyer so i can't
comment on the legal case but we rely on
the society to make sure that our kid
doesn't get hit by a drunk driver that
the food that we eat in a restaurant
doesn't make us terribly sick that the
rest that the medicines we pick up at
the pharmacy are not contaminated in the
same way we need the government and
society to be able to protect us if a
more dangerous variant comes or another
health threat comes so how much does
this really matter we heard from the
immuno-compromised person in errol's
piece if if you're wearing a mask
yourself one-way masking as it's called
and everyone else is not how much of a
difference does that make you're a lot
safer if everyone is masking that's why
we are all connected and that connection
means that my health depends on what you
do but if other people around aren't
masked then if you're immunity
compromised older then up your mask game
to an n95 it's not perfect but it's more
protective than a cloth mask or a
surgical mask how concerned are you
about immunocompromised compromised
people traveling on planes my father for
example we've talked about bringing our
families to south africa it's a 12-14
hour flight no one's mass but he's
masked what would you recommend
unfortunately if you're immunosuppressed
or otherwise medically vulnerable flying
just got less safe for you now it's
really hard to wear a mask for 10 12 14
hours but that's what you might have to
do if you want to reduce your risk for
yourself personally if all of us were
masked up all of us would be safer so it
sounds like you're saying you he
probably shouldn't get on a plane for
that long you know it's a risk benefit
calculation how important is that trip
to you how important is that meeting
with that meal and if it's important
then you do it staying as safe as
possible meaning an n95 mask for the
whole way cases are already going up now
don't you think this will mean cases
will continue to go up
that's what i struggle with and i
struggle with people making the decision
i'm not going to mask if you could not
wear a mask and it only affects you good
on you but it affects so many other
people
with cases going up the idea of masks
coming down doesn't make a lot of sense
but we don't know what's going to happen
yet either with the severity of this
particular wave in terms of
hospitalization we have great vaccines
great treatments we need more people to
get them
but the biggest concern is what's going
to happen in the coming months what if
we have a more dangerous variant that's
deadly that gets away from our
vaccine-induced immunity we really need
these kind of tools to protect people
not just to save lives but also to keep
our economy growing what about kids that
can't be vaccinated we've seen
can't get the vaccine and aren't wearing
the mask we've seen just yesterday new
data out from the cdc very severe
illness and hundreds of kids almost all
of them unvaccinated between the ages of
6 and 11. so very important to get
vaccinated boosted up to date and to
mask up to recommend it at least and uh
when disease is spreading spreading a
lot to require it important to let
parents know the vast majority of
children do absolutely fine if they're
healthy and they have no underlying
absolutely uh we're still waiting to
hear from the cdc uh meantime dr tom
frieden thank you very much for being
here we appreciate it